hi in this video we will talk about how
pancreatic beta-cell secretes insulin we
would understand the physiological
context and the molecular mechanism by
which insulin secretion takes place so
let's start here is our pancreas if you
zoom in to our pancreas and try to take
a cross-section the pancreas would
somewhat look like this and if we look
at these green cells which are the
depiction of beta cells now these beta
cells secrete influent there are other
cell types also present in the pancreas
which we are not focusing right now but
let's just focus on the pancreatic beta
cells and try to understand that how
pancreatic beta cell secret ensuing note
that pancreatic beta-cell are very few
in number compared to the other cell
types present here now the pancreatic
beta cell has specific gene expression
pattern it expresses the is one gene
which is located at the chromosome 11 P
15.5 locus now this particular gene
encodes for insulin insulin is a protein
easiest hormone so insulin has to be or
the precursor form of the insulin has to
be encoded by the gene and it is I&S
gene which encodes the insulin now let's
look at this process in bit more details
that how insulin synthesis or insulin
biogenesis takes place so from the
insulin gene look at in the eleventh
chromosome the mRNA would be produced
now this mRNA once transcribed from the
insulin gene it would be moving out
through the nuclear pore and on the top
of the rough endoplasmic reticulum the
ribosomes which is sitting there they
would convert the mRNA I mean they would
translate the mRNA into peptide now
these peptides at the precursor from
form of the insulin now these peptides
are going to be packaged inside the
endoplasmic
then it would move to Golgi from there
it would be mobilized as a secretory
vesicle so first it is packaged in
endoplasmic reticulum then further it
would be it would be moved to the cells
secretory pathway via the Golgi
apparatus and it would be almost ready
to secrete now inside the secretory
vesicle there are specific enzymes such
as hormone converters and carboxy
peptidase which would cleave the sea
peptide of the ensuing in this case the
sea peptide is depicted as an orange
bead of string now the insulin hormone
would be now packaged inside these
vesicles secretory vesicles and ready to
be secreted now since this is gene is
expressing most of the time insulin is
always ready insulin is ready and it is
Queen packaged inside the vesicle ready
to be secreted but without a particular
context insulin is not secreted by the
pancreatic beta-cell so what is the
context here so insulin would be only
secreted when the glucose level is high
and it would try to divert the glucose
inside the cells such that the cells can
utilize the glucose that's the function
of the insulin now how does at the first
place the pitcher cell knows that there
is ample amount of glucose present in
the bloodstream the answer is simple
right insulin is packaged in the vesicle
but waiting for a signal to be
discharged and the signal is basically
the blood glucose level so let's say you
have it in a donor tasty doughnut and
the doughnut will be broken down and
it's monosaccharides lot of glucose
would be actually absorbed in the
intestine and from the intestine the
glucose would be elevated in your
bloodstream but still it doesn't answer
that how pancreatic cell would
understand that glucose elevation took
place in the bloodstream so pancreatic
beta-cells
specific channels or transporters I
would say these are called blue to
glucose transporter 2 here depicted as
this blue on channels this glute 2 would
allow glucose to enter from the blood
vessel now the pancreas has many blood
vessels supplying blood flow in the
pancreas so these glucose which is
carried in the blood flow would also get
inside the pancreatic beta-cell and
thereby it would trigger the secretion
of insulin which are already packaged
and ready inside the vesicle but let's
just delve into the details of the
molecular mechanism so let's see the
process again what happens when glucose
is absent what happens when glucose is
present when glucose is absent in
absence of glucose the pancreatic
beta-cell is in a hyper polarized state
in that situation one particular
potassium channel which is ATP dependent
is 1 as a result potassium leaks out and
the cell is hyperpolarized but when
buca's comes in glucose gets converted
to glucose 6-phosphate entered like all
is his pathway and from glycolysis
pathway we know there would be ATP
production and it eventually the glucose
would be also used to produce ATP but
when there is glucose there would be ATP
and this ATP would eventually inhibit
this potassium channel or the leaky
potassium channel
so once potassium is not moving out the
cells would be rather going to a
depolarized state in this situation
several calcium channel also open in the
pancreatic beta-cell which allows
calcium influx inside the cell now
calcium helps in vesicle docking events
these vesicles which are filled with
insulin are ready they are packaged with
insulin they are waiting for a trigger
to be released and that trigger for
release is the elevation of the camp
calcium which is due to elevation of
glucose level in the pancreatic
beta-cell now the calcium would help to
modulate the snare complexes and allow
the fusion of this vesicle with the
membrane which would allow the insulin
to be secreted and once the insulin is
secreted it is ready to perform its job
but how does insulin perform its job do
you want to know Indians
inertia you know that you have to watch
my second video about how in fluid is
the mechanism of insulin action action
so I hope this video was informative
this video was helpful if you liked this
video give it a quick thumbs up and
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
and do let me know in the comment how do
you like my videos your comment give me
so much positive motivation to make more
videos thank you